bonsoir merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors dans la rue la colère
éclate de nouveau les manifestations se
multiplient depuis la double explosion
cette catastrophe c'est le drame de trop
pour le liban dont seule madame
effectivement c'est le drame de trop
j'aimerais juste fait une petite
observation
je ne pense pas que le qualificatif de
négligence que vous avez utilisé tout à
l'heure pour juger l'action du
gouvernement soit le bon il s'agit d'un
crime prémédité
l'ensemble de la classe politique les
députés ministres les trois présidents
des chefs des partis savait parfaitement
qu'il y avait ces explosifs europol et
ils n'ont absolument rien fait pour les
enlever de là ils ont le mépris du
peuple libanais et comme je vous le
disais c'est un acte c'est un meurtre
prémédité et ces gens là doivent être
punis pour avoir laissé ses explosifs là
où ils sont en trop sur cette colère
également qu' qui grandit dans la rue
elle et elle est logique attendue cette
colère ces manifestations qui se
multiplient et c'est l'évidence même
bien sûr qu'attendez-vous de gens qui
ont tout perdu et lorsque je dis tout
perdu ce n'est pas une métaphore
ce n'est pas à 9 emmys c'est la réalité
ils ont perdu des parents ils ont perdu
leur maison ils ont perdu leur travail
on leur a volé par la politique
économique de ce pouvoir corrompu tout
les jeux tout l'argent qu'ils avaient
dans les banques ce jeu qu attendez vous
de la part de citoyens qui sont denses
dans cet état et je pense le moment ne
va pas ses rites et les des missions
s'enchaînent parmi les parlementaires on
compte celles de la ministre de
l'information a également aujourd'hui le
gouvernement de hassan diab il
vit ses derniers instants écoutez pour
ce qui est la démission des ministres
d'abord ce sont les rats qui quittent
les navires se sont que des seconds
couteaux qui ont vendu leur âme pour un
marocain et qui ont accepté d'être les
ci-devant du véritable pouvoir qui lui
ailleurs qui est chez les partis
confessionnels qui tiennent le pays
depuis 30 ans par ailleurs en ce qui
concerne les élections législatives
cette la ficelle est grosse et un piège
grossier que le pouvoir tant relie
banner nous savons tous que les
élections sont falsifiés sont financés
par l'argent que les partis
confessionnels reçoivent de leurs
maîtres les you know et qu'ils feront
tout pour ge renouveler un mandat qui
n'a rien de populaire
donc tant qu'il y aura pas une
commission indépendante et un contrôle
indépendant libanais et internationale
pour mener les élections la même classe
politique va revenir et me semble parti
pour l'exacerbation de tous les
problèmes du liban donc vous êtes plutôt
d'accord avec ce qu'a proposé manuel
macro à ces derniers jours lors de sa
visite au liban
non pas du tout écoutez la visite des
manuels ma que l'on en fait il
s'agissait de deux visites
une première visite où il a exprimé la
solidarité de la france avec le liban
ce dont on lemercier la france nous
avons l'habitude de ce genre de réaction
puis il ya la seconde visite qui est une
visite politique où il a annoncé lors de
sa conférence de presse qui voulait un
gouvernement d'union nationale
que veut dire un gouvernement d'union
nationale c'est à dire un gouvernement
qui va ramener les mêmes partir au puy
politique les mêmes partis
confessionnels qui ont mis à sac le pays
pendant 30 ans et qui empêchent par tous
les moyens légaux et illégaux
l'émergence d'une véritable opposition
donc non je ne suis pas d'accord avec la
proposition
sion du président maclan pardonnez moi
un mini ça mais on vous sent très
défaitiste
quand vous parlez de de la politique du
liban de l'avenir du pays on vous sent
très des défaitistes pas très peur je
sais que je suis pas du tout défaitisme
madame je suis en collège nous avons
déjà eu deux cents morts et 100 disparus
qui vont vraisemblablement suivre les
précédents
cinq mille appartements ont été dévastés
la moitié de la ville est par terre des
milliards sont partis en fumée je suis
simplement en collège je suis en colère
comme tous les citoyens et je peux vous
assurer que le cette fois c'est la
dernière que ce pouvoir va tomber il est
tombé moralement il ne reste plus qu'à
tomber physiquement c'est une n'est plus
qu'une question de temps
un tank plus ou moins court mais croyez
moi c'en est fini
cette fois les libanais ne vont pas
reculer ils vont retrouver leur liberté
qu'ils ont défendu bec et ongles hop où
les envahisseurs qui sont assis lien où
il serait il ya ce n'est pas un peuple
qui baisse les bras
nous finirons par nous débarrasser de
cette classe politique afin d'être sûr
la conférence de soutien au liban qui a
eu lieu aujourd'hui par vidéo conférence
les participants se sont engagés sur une
aide de 250 millions d'euros
ce soutien cet accompagnement de la
communauté internationale il est
indispensable aujourd'hui pour le liban
bien sûr qu'il est indispensable puisque
cette classe politique a vidé les
caisses de l'état et a engagé une dette
de 90 milliards
à ce jour nous les en remercions mais
nous avons fait comprendre à tous les
donateurs et à monsieur maquereau en
particulier qui venu au liban que cet
agent ne devrait pas être versée
directement au gouvernement parce qu'ils
se les dilapider qui seraient volés par
le système de corruption et de
clientélisme qui est en cours que cette
agence devrait être versée directement
aux organisations non gouvernementales
qui au cours de la guerre civile
et jusqu'à maintenant ont fait la preuve
de la plus grande transparence et
efficacité
et que les gros projet de la
construction soit directement piloté par
les états donateurs
je donner de l'argent à ce gouvernement
cela veut dire lui redonner un second
souffle et cela est inadmissible
ça sera le mot de la fin à miner sa
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle vous êtes coordinateur de la
direction politique du bloc national
merci beaucoup